just think of the devil no I'm not
saying he's the devil but I was just
thinking they had a yard but a decision
in the session yet so here we here we go
again yeah I played a bit of the Queen's
Indian recently experimenting them yeah
I got a great position against him
recently with this line okay now is
playing differently III yeah why not hmm
ok let's just develop him maybe maybe
aphorism I wonder if you should do this
I really i have no no experience in
those positions or no no no it's a bit
much but very very little c5 looks kind
of normal
i wonder if i should do this this trade
Sam don't we don't know I know that
rupee aid is often a plan for Bishop f a
g6 sent and this kind of things so I'm
going for that not thinking too long
about this whenever he takes d5 I take
these three with the tempo I have to
have a look at this undefended a six
Bishop I wonder if well let's do that
first okay so Roxy eight was my idea or
taking let's do look see it
sometimes I know that night h5 is an
idea night age 52 f 4 if he lets me well
I probably won't it this is an idea to
sometimes exploit that the bishop is on
b2 and not naturally defending a form i
wonder if Knight a5 is a mafia or is
this crazy could be risky the smooth
let's do that looks interesting at least
to check him here and put some pressure
on see form it is risky because of that
exactly but i was thinking i have rookie
7 or not oh oopsie 70 ok i thought i
think i should be ok maybe night of 796
or something but his queen is only two i
really cannot believe that it is
decisive already but it's always
dangerous to give him this kind of this
kind of attacking attacking position ok
ok i was thinking instead stake here
first
oh I came I was thinking BCDC rook
chicks but then have seven hangs of
course so that's not not so easy I go
night night night move I move the night
to h5 or somewhere chai will probably
retreat that
hi age six is a move okay so but here I
can really take twice yeah because on
before at the end i have night see form
let's just do that be four night c for
loop take six on bitchin methods that
should be should be okay threaten might
be to him Knight takes group chase is
fine situation is still a bit unclear I
mean have won I've won and have one upon
the sea porn and so on 94 looks kind of
normal might see six maybe I can go I
can go anywhere rite aid or what a queen
80 is just allowing that um why so C
seven so strong on group Queen B seven
book is seven I don't get it OIC going
somewhere I don't I don't see it that's
played my point is dangerous I mean
anyway but it seems her should play that
let move him
don't see a way to punish me queen bee
7i 0 7 maybe 97 threatening Cecil and
also by the way is this is a mate Queen
f7 ssome 80 I don't don't see him chick
meeting me at the moment there it's very
close though rookie 790 790 1c7 I can
take g7 what's the problem I don't see
it ok I'm let's start with that oh
that's the idea ok time morning grabbing
this to this is quinium White Rose I'm
it wasn't it wasn't a real idea yeah I
just T I just get to get the pawn yeah
it still kind of shocked yeah yeah I
don't know he lost his way there somehow
one key moment was was definitely about
here when when it is my move I really I
really felt that this is a bit shaky
yeah the compounds to and so sec here
give us this as about equal or a a form
where route III I don't know yeah I'm
definitely willing to believe that this
is something that what should play now
it switches to equal very difficult to
evaluate this position I know in terms
of intuitively it feels that this bishop
here is a little bit too bad to give
white more than compensation but maybe
it just goes back there and when I
donate five is really bad I know that's
very unclear
and now I just crept down I don't know
maybe it's maybe there's a problem with
that move yeah there's a problem night
except 7s central parade check check so
again sacrifice and now i'm in this in
this fork yeah comsys white is slightly
but I what to do with this evaluation
what what does a piece down for just one
pond but well he definitely has
something but what exactly is it that
that he has i really i really think that
i'm very very interesting if i go here
the compounds to do this which is cute
lamp edittext the night and it threatens
bishop f6 due to this rookie I'm
difficult to play a movie actually this
is just very awkward ha so can I go
somewhere else if i go back then I g4
killed Wow okay yeah that would probably
have one for him at least in a practical
game well okay yeah well I didn't I
didn't think about nine f7 I was just
glad that I had this this thing again
night of seven is interesting but yeah
i'm just-just much better right yeah
yeah i'm much better here Queen beside
the Council believes that this is kind
of possible why I made a huge
calculation mistake there I was actually
thinking that here i can i can take the
take here which is of course check not
really is it great i mean i can't play
that but i was thinking I better but I'm
not hmm
yeah that's just blunders the house I
don't know what you did there plate that
quickly huh that's some kind of pre move
I don't know it's very very weird yeah
97's what she has to do c7 check check
we get this yet position where I have
Bishop Bishop look and to Center pawns
Jim if I manage to coordinate my pieces
I'm certainly okay but I don't know
night and queen always a bit dangerous
ja very tough game okay i hope you liked
it it was a good fight anyway thanks for
watching